You know, they say the best things in life
are free, like headshots!
I’m Colin for theScore esports and this
week on Best of, we’re pinching our pennies
and taking a look at the best eco rounds and force buys in CS:GO.
I mean, you know how it is.
You spent all that cash on AWP no armour get your sh-t wrecked, and now your team’s dirt poor.
But have no fear, because even on default
pistols, magic can happen.
Just ask the players in our first section.
I’m all out of money!
And just to be clear here guys, when we say default pistols, I’m talking about rounds where
the majority of team is USPs or Glocks.
P250, CZ here and there, meh it doesn’t
bother me.
(casting)
I declare bankruptcy!
So not all eco rounds are a complete wash.
Sometimes you got a
little bit of cash and it’s burning a hole in your pocket.
And before you teammates and type “save”, you’ve blown your wad on that sweet sweet Scout.
Don’t tell me how to spend my money.
I mean, you gotta spend money to make money right?
(casting)
Oh, great Odin’s raven.
Not like this, not like this.
(casting)
It's free real estate.
Ever find 20 bucks in
your coat pocket?
I’m talkin bout this.
Feels good, right?
Well, not as good as finding an AK-47 on the ground when you’ve invested little or
nothing in the round.
(casting)
Well guys, that’s all we’ve got
for you on Best of this week.
Now, I’m not gonna lie to you, my whole
life is like an eco round... maybe a force buy at best.
So go ahead, hit that like button, and sub to the channel, and put your boi Colin on that full buy.